this was an earlier scene and the idea
of it was that it would be interesting
to see Edna's usual job ease first love
is to do fashions for superheroes super
where and it itches both her design side
and her tech side but the supers are
illegal in the world of The Incredibles
and she doesn't get to work
with superheroes very much most of her
work consists of regular fashion for
regular models and this is how she goes
about it I'm sorry to do this to you I
know you're busy but I didn't know where
else to go
Helens and journalistic problems Robert
of a superhero nature destroy chat jack
has powers and not just one many and
they're all over the place he's bursting
into flames
he's shooting lasers out of his eyes
he's floating between dimensions
fascinating here's a polymorph handling
I endorse your decision I'm operating a
no sleep I'm telling you this baby is
freaking me out I don't know where he's
gonna be I don't know what he's gonna be
bad anything can happen
and I've got to respond Robert what what
the baby is gone
[Applause]
[Music]
like if they're Tom Frei they're going
crazy they want you to take a bow and
they want the glitter baby no glitter
baby first the team will bow and the
junior designers then I will come now
click that baby you see what I'm dealing
with is he gonna be liquid or fire
lasers or turn into a beach ball I don't
know and if I don't know what he's gonna
be how am I gonna contain him you gotta
help me
you need to simultaneously protect the
baby and the surroundings and track the
baby's movements should he disappear
from view you're a lucky Robert I am
intrigued
[Music]